It now transitions into the
most important events following
that incident and that is the
start
Hedgehola, the start of the
main obligatory Hijrah of all
of the Muslims, all that could
from Mecca to Medina.
It's important for us to have a
few introductory issues ironed
out before we get into this.
The first is looking at the
actual word El Hidra.
Al Hijra. Lugatan.
For Sharia.
[Silence]
tells us about Hijra. We have
to discuss Hijra as a
legislation in Islam. Hijra in
the Arabic language Adam
logically means to abandon
something, to leave something
and what is meant by it in
Islamic law and Islamic
jurisprudence is leaving a
place that a person is unable
to outwardly embrace Islam. To
outwardly practice Islam. This
is the opinion of the majority
of the scholar of Islam. Hijra
was not obligatory in the first
years of the prophet
prophethood. Up until about the
tenth year after he was
appointed a prophet. Then we
see that Hijalah is starting to
be eluded to. So Allah would
send down verses speaking about
how Ibrahim migrated. How? Lord
migrated. He did Hijra. Right?
We have our Ibrahim and Surat
Mariam. did and migrated and
we have different verses here
and there that kind of
articulate that this is
something that is approaching.
Then, we have the obligation to
make hijra. It became
obligatory to make so what is
hijra? Hijra? Migration that is
obligatory is that a person
leave the land that they are in
or leave the place that they
are in where they are unable to
outwardly
practice their
religion As soon as they get to
a place where they can practice
their religion, which could be,
you know, a few miles away back
then. Now, it might be an issue
of of national law in certain
countries, right? So, a person
would have to migrate to any
place in the Earth where they
can outwardly embrace and
practice their religion. What
do we mean by men
[Silence]
manifest their religion
outwardly practice their
religion. We mean that a person
is able to say I'm Muslim to
say to profess that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah. To
establish prayer. To make to
fast during the month of
Ramadan. To go to make Hajj.
Right?
these especially these basic
tenets of Islam that a person
must be able to establish these
basic tenets of Islam. It
doesn't mean that a person is
able to establish every single
ruling of Islam. Because that
ruling of Islam depends on
the law that the person is
living under. So, their person
might be living in a place
where they can manifest the
major five pillars of Islam,
the major aspects of their
religion, certain things are
regulated differently and this
means that that community is
too small to start to govern
themselves, right? And the
companions lived under those
circumstances. When we look at
hey, in this sense
we see that the best hijra in
the time of the prophet so the
was to leave whatever land a
person was in and migrate to
Medina. Right? But we see that
the bare minimum was to migrate
from A land where a person was
unable to manifest his religion
to anywhere they are able to
worship Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala freely and you know,
there are places especially
there are in the 20th century.
You know, the for instance, the
Soviet Union when it swept the
world and the iron curtain, we
see that historically religion
is
[Silence]
religion is minimized and full
of religion or ostracized and
specifically Muslims. So, a
person is unable to practice
his or her religion in this
place and there are still
communist countries China
for instance and many places in
China. We, you know, she leaked
League stories of Muslims that
are being forced to break their
fast during Ramadan. Muslims
who are prohibited from
praying. Muslims who are given
particular things of that they
have to say everyday and
allegiances that they have to
pledge and so forth. If a
person's able to leave this
kind of place and migrate from
there, it's obligatory upon
them to migrate from there. So,
This is the main issue with
regards to Hijalah. Now,
Hijalah from Mecca was
obligatory. Hijalah from Mecca
to Medina to Medina. So,
Hijalah from Mecca. At that
time, was obligatory. Hijara to
Medina was preferred. Was
[Arabic recitation]
markets and commerce was
something that was seasonal.
People would usually come to
Mecca from all the Arab
Peninsula and also from Hashem
and Iraq and all over the
place. They would all
congregate and muster together
there in Mecca for Hajj season.
And they would also come there
for seasonal markets. Right?
Because of the different of the
different seasons. Some would
come from Yemen during a
certain season with things that
are seasonal. Fruits that are
seasonal or things that are
seasonal. And during certain
months people would come from
the north from Hashem to Mecca
with seasonal things and so
there were seasonal
marketplaces.
Is one of them. Is one of them.
These are different markets
that were seasonal at that
time. So, the prophet would
take the would take the
opportunity of Hajj, the
opportunity of these markets to
go there and to call people to
Islam and to call the major
tribesmen of different Arab
regions to Islam in order to
find someone or some tribe that
would accept him, take him in,
protect him, and allow him to
establish himself with the rest
of the Muslims. And so the
prophet would do this. And
during these times he would go
to each and every single tribe.
And he would go to every
marketplace. And he would go to
every area. And different legs
and journeys of Hajj and invite
the people individually and
collectively to Islam. However,
the nobility of Mecca or the
nobility of Quraish, the
notables of Quresh Abu
Lahab, had taken it upon
themselves to follow him around
Anywhere he went and try to
convince otherwise. So, the
prophet would walk through the
marketplaces and say, oh
people, say you will become
successful. You will come to
reign over the Arabs and the
non Arabs will bend to your
will. And if you die upon you
will all be, you will all reign
as kings in paradise. And Abu
Lahab would follow him around
and say, do not obey this man.
He is an apostate. He is a
liar. An apostate meaning from
the religion of his
forefathers. And so people were
fooled by this propaganda. So
many of them would say, look,
your own tribes people don't
accept your religion. This
religion that you claim. They
don't accept you as a prophet.
They're calling you a magician.
They're calling you a madman.
Why should we accept you and
people don't accept you.
Obviously, they know you better
than we do, right? And the
prophet also went to individual
tribes some of these tribes
that
went to and called to Islam and
who rejected his calling to
Islam and there's a number of
reasons for this. I mean, if
you were with the prophet
during that period, that time
when he was going to each and
every tribesmen, each and every
tribe, each and every region,
calling them to Islam, and they
are insulting him and rejecting
him. If we had with him during
that time. Be very hard to hold
on to one's faith during those
times because look, how much
effort is being put forth and
how little fruits are coming as
a result of those efforts. But
this is one of the one of the
tests that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions.
With the
So we see that this is a test
that
[Silence]
worry about quality, right? And
to look at the glasses half
full rather than half empty.
There's a lot of reasons for
that. The point is is that
it would seem pretty hopeless
at that point but there's a
reason for that. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala did not
will for that to happen yet
because it wasn't time. Mecca
had not heard enough. Enough
Quran wasn't sent down. The
Muslims weren't ready to move
and migrate. you know it
wasn't time yet. And second of
all the prophet had a very
specific place that he was to
end up and that is in Medina.
Known at the time as Yathrib.
And in inhabited by three
Jewish tribes and
these are the two Arab tribes
of Yethrib at that time. We'll
talk about this next time. This
is our last class till the end
of Ramadan. After Ramadan is
over, we will you will start
over inshallah. This class, we
will continue in it until we're
finished. We're about halfway
through the book. So, almost
done which is an achievement.
[Arabic recitation]